so you saw what's happening in New York
question is why is the outbreak so
especially devastating their New York
City is the densest metro area in the
country that's the most obvious answer
probably the biggest problem the city
also has an awful lot of people
traveling to and from other infected
countries and that's significant too but
it's not the whole story as this deadly
virus emerged from eastern China and
began to spread inexorably across the
globe clearly headed here leaders in New
York not only failed to shield their
citizens from it they took affirmative
and aggressive steps to increase the
risk to their population why would they
do that
well because they were worried far more
about being called racist than
protecting human lives it's not an
overstatement that's not hyperbole watch
the city's health commissioner Osiris
Barban urge New Yorkers to spend as much
time as possible in crowded public
places keep in mind this video was from
February 2nd of this year that was long
after the threat from the Chinese Crona
virus was obvious to anyone who was
paying attention the risk to New Yorkers
for coronavirus is low and that our
preparedness as a city is very high
there is no reason not to take the
subway not to take the bus not to go out
to your favorite restaurant and
certainly not to miss the parade next
Sunday take the subway go to dinner
people cheer they feel good about
themselves
future generations though are gonna
watch that video with their jaws open in
disbelief how could someone charged with
protecting public health so recklessly
in danger it the watch this performance
from State Senator John Liu to lose
suggests that people who might be
concerned in any way about contracting a
deadly disease or who might be
interested in where it came from
must be and you guessed it bigots but
there's really no need to panic and to
avoid activities that we always do as
New Yorkers we are Hardy people as an
asian-american
I've been somewhat disturbed if not
outright appalled at some of the
comments or gestures that I have
diseases originate from anywhere or from
particular places in the world in other
words as a member of a protected
interest group I'm ordering you to
ignore this threat to your family on
moral grounds go to the parade or else
that's what Lou is saying let's hope
that in the wake of this disaster after
John Lou has lost his job and we can all
think clearly again people will stop
talking this way in public for good it
was always the most brutal form of
social control masquerading as
sensitivity and caring now we know it
was infecting the public with disease
but at the time sentiments like this
were universal among big city public
officials state senator Brian Kavanaugh
for example decided to embark on a
crusade against what he called
misinformation a euphemism as it so
often is for accurate information
Cavanaugh encouraged people to head to
Chinatown for a festival it's very
important that we recognize that this
holiday and this festival is of
tremendous significance for many
communities in our state and it is very
important that we ensure that we don't
have misinformation and many in the
media have been covering this issue as
if it's you know a terrible plague that
people have to avoid if you don't go to
a crowded public place immediately
you're racist look at those people
telling you that demanding that you do
that hectoring you badgering you
exerting moral blackmail on you to
expose yourself by early March
coronavirus was clearly becoming a major
problem in the United States but for
elected officials in New York the only
problem was their constituents racist
worries about staying alive on March 2nd
this March 2nd Mayor Bill de Blasio
tweeted this quote since I'm encouraging
New Yorkers to go on with your lives
plus get out on the town despite
coronavirus I thought it would offer
some suggestions here's the 1st through
Thursday go see the trader if the wire
was a true story plus set in Italy it
would be this film that's right go to a
movie theater immediately you must a
week later de Blasio was still
encouraging the
- live it up and mingle in large groups
on March 11th which keep in mind was
barely two weeks ago de Blasio was still
insisting that quote if you're not sick
you should be going about your life that
very same day the NBA announced it was
suspending its whole season Italy was
already several days into a national
lockdown but the mayor of one of the
world's most crowded cities was telling
everyone to carry on as though the
Chinese coronavirus was just a racist
myth soon after that people in New York
inevitably started to get sick in some
cases very sick in some cases they died
and then suddenly de Blasio was on Meet
the Press shrieking that Donald Trump
had abandoned the city it was their
fault all their fault that line almost
always works which is why de Blasio did
it the media play along and move on to
the next thing and no one remembers what
actually happened well that happened
this time maybe not this time might be
different this pandemic is too horrible
too many people are getting hurt nobody
really liked identity politics anyway
all it did was help mediocrities like
Bill de Blasio get elected to office but
it was disgusting and cruel and divisive
and now we know it can get people killed
maybe we can stop